The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Particles
in quantum mechanics.
In particular, the ones that are
identical and non-interacting.
So basically, we were focusing
on a type of Hamiltonian
for a system of N
particles, which
could be written as the sum of
contributions that correspond
respectively to particle
1, particle 2, particle N.
So essentially, a sum of
terms that are all the same.
And one-particle
terms is sufficient
because we don't
have interactions.
So if we look at one of
these H's-- so one of these
one-particle Hamiltonians, we
said that we could find some
kind of basis for it.
In particular, typically we
were interested in particles
in the box.
We would label them
with some wave number k.
And there was an associated
one-particle energy,
which for the case of
one-particle in box
was h bar squared
k squared over 2m.
But in general, for the
one-particle system,
we can think of a ladder of
possible values of energies.
So there will be some
k1, k2, k3, et cetera.
They may be distributed in any
particular way corresponding
to different energies.
Basically, you
would have a number
of possible states
for one particle.
So for the case of the particle
in the box, the wave functions
and coordinate space that we
had x, k were of the form e
to the i k dot x divided
by square root of V.
We allowed the energies where h
bar squared k squared over 2m.
And this discretization
was because the values of k
were multiples of 2 pi over
l with integers in the three
different directions.
Assuming periodic
boundary conditions
or appropriate discretization
for closed boundary conditions,
or whatever you have.
So that's the
one-particle state.
If the Hamiltonian
is of this form,
it is clear that we can
multiply a bunch of these states
and form another
eigenstate for HN.
Those we were calling
product states.
So you basically pick a
bunch of these k's and you
multiply them.
So you have k1, k2, kN.
And essentially, that
would correspond,
let's say, in coordinate
representation
to taking a bunch of x's and
the corresponding k's and having
a wave function of the form e to
the i k alp-- sum over alpha k
alpha x alpha, and then
divided by V to the N over 2.
So in this procedure,
what did we do?
We had a number of possibilities
for the one-particle state.
And in order to, let's say,
make a two-particle state,
we would pick two of
these k's and multiply
the corresponding
wave functions.
If you had three particles,
we could pick another one.
If you had four particles,
we could potentially
pick a second one
twice, et cetera.
So in general,
basically we would
put N of these crosses on
these one-particle states
that we've selected.
Problem was that
this was not allowed
by quantum mechanics
for identical particles.
Because if we took one
of these wave functions
and exchanged two of
the labels, x1 and x2,
we could potentially get
a different wave function.
And in quantum mechanics, we
said that the wave function
has to be either symmetric or
anti-symmetric with respect
to exchange of a
pair of particles.
And also, whatever it implied
for repeating this exchange
many times to look at all
possible permutations.
So what we saw was that
product states are good
as long as you
are thinking about
distinguishable particles.
But if you have
identical particles,
you had to appropriately
symmetrize or anti-symmetrize
these states.
So what we ended up was
a wabe of, for example,
symmetrizing things for
the case of fermions.
So we could take a bunch
of these k-values again.
And a fermionic, or
anti-symmetrized version,
was then constructed by
summing over all permutations.
And for N particle, there would
be N factorial permutations.
Basically, doing a
permutation of all of these
indices k1, k2, et cetera,
that we had selected for this.
And for the case
of fermions, we had
to multiply each
permutation with a sign that
was plus for even permutations,
minus for odd permutations.
And this would give
us N factorial terms.
And the appropriate
normalization
was 1 over square
root of N factorial.
So this was for the
case of fermions.
And this was actually minus.
I should have put
in a minus here.
And this would have
been minus to the P.
For the case of
bosons, we basically
dispensed with this factor
of minus 1 to the P.
So we had a Pk.
Now, the corresponding
normalization that we had here
was slightly different.
The point was that
if we were doing
this computation for
the case of fermions,
we could not allow
a state where there
is a double occupation of one
of the one-particle state.
Under exchange of
the particles that
would correspond
to these k-values,
I would get the same state back,
but the exchange would give me
a minus 1 and it
would give me 0.
So the fermionic wave function
that I have constructed
here, appropriately
anti-symmetrized,
exists only as long as
there are no repeats.
Whereas, for the case of bosons,
I could put 2 over same place.
I could put 3 somewhere else,
any number that I liked,
and there would be
no problem with this.
Except that the normalization
would be more complicated.
And we saw that
appropriate normalization
was a product over
k nk factorial.
So this was for fermions.
This is for bosons.
And the two I can
submerge into one formula
by writing a symmetrized
or anti-symmetrized state,
respectively indicated by eta,
where we have eta is minus 1
for fermions and eta
is plus 1 for bosons,
which is 1 over square
root of N factorial product
over k nk factorials.
And then the sum over all
N factorial permutations.
This phase factor for fermions
and nothing for bosons
of the appropriately
permuted set of k's.
And in this way
of noting things,
I have to assign values nk which
are either 0 or 1 for fermions.
Because as we said, multiple
occupations are not allowed.
But there is no
restriction for bosons.
Except of course, that
in this perspective,
as I go along this k-axis,
I have 0, 1, 0, 2, 1, 3, 0,
0 for the occupations.
Of course, what I
need to construct
whether I am dealing
with bosons or fermions
is that the sum over k nk is
the total number of particles
that I have.
Now, the other thing to note
is that once I have given you
a picture such as this in terms
of which one-particle states
I want to look at, or which
set of occupation numbers
I have nk, then
there is one and only
one symmetrized or
anti-symmetrized state.
So over here, I
could have permuted
the k's in a number
of possible ways.
But as a result
of symmetrization,
anti-symmetrization,
various ways
of permuting the
labels here ultimately
come to the same set
of occupation numbers.
So it is possible to actually
label the state rather than
by the set of k's.
By the set of nk's.
It is kind of a more appropriate
way of representing the system.
So that's essentially
the kinds of states
that we are going to be using.
Again, in talking about
identical particles,
which could be either
bosons or fermions.
Let's take a step back,
remind you of something
that we did before that
had only one particle.
Because I will soon
go to many particles.
But before that,
let's remind you
what the one particle
in a box looked like.
So indeed, in this case,
the single-particle states
were the ones that
I told you before,
2 pi over l some
set of integers.
Epsilon k, that was h bar
squared k squared over 2m.
If I want to calculate
the partition function
for one particle in the box,
I have to do a trace of e
to the minus beta
h for one particle.
The trace I can very
easily calculate
in the basis in which
this is diagonal.
That's the basis
that is parameterized
by these k-values.
So I do a sum over k of
e to the minus beta h
bar squared k squared over 2m.
And then in the limit
of very large box,
we saw that the sum
over k I can replace
with V integral
over k 2 pi cubed.
This was the density
of states in k.
e to the minus beta h bar
squared k squared over 2m.
And this was three
Gaussian integrals
that gave us the usual formula
of V over lambda cubed, where
lambda was this thermal
[INAUDIBLE] wavelength
h root 2 pi mk.
But we said that the essence
of statistical mechanics
is to tell you
about probabilities
of various micro-states, various
positions of the particle
in the box, which in
the quantum perspective
is probability becomes
a density matrix.
And we evaluated
this density matrix
in the coordinate
representation.
And in the coordinate
representation,
essentially what
we had to do was
to go into the basis in
which rho is diagonal.
So we had x prime k.
In the k basis, the density
matrix is just this formula.
It's the Boltzmann weight
appropriately normalized by Z1.
And then we go kx.
And basically,
again replacing this
with V integral d cubed k 2 pi
cubed e to the minus beta h bar
squared k squared over 2m.
These two factors of xk and x
prime k gave us a factor of e
to the kx, xk I have as
ik dot x prime minus x.
Completing the square.
Actually, I had to divide by Z1.
There is a factor of 1 over
V from the normalization
of these things.
The two V's here cancel,
but Z1 is proportional to V.
The lambda cubes
cancel and so what
we have is 1 over
V e to the minus x
minus x prime squared
pi over lambda squared.
So basically, what
you have here is
that we have a box
of volume V. There
is a particle inside
at some location x.
And the probability
to find it at location
x is the diagonal
element of this entity.
It's just 1 over
V. But this entity
has off-diagonal elements
reflecting the fact
that the best that you can do
to localize something in quantum
mechanics is to make some
kind of a wave packet.
OK.
So this we did last time.
What we want to do now is
to go from one particle
to the case of N particles.
So rather than
having 1x prime, I
will have a whole bunch of x
primes labeled 1 through N.
And I want to calculate the N
particle density matrix that
connects me from set of points
x to another set of points
x prime.
So if you like in
the previous picture,
this would have been
x1 and x1 prime,
and then I now have x2 and x2
prime, x3 and x3 prime, xN and
xN prime.
I have a bunch of
different coordinates
and I'd like to calculate that.
OK.
Once more, we know that rho
is diagonal in the basis that
is represented by
these occupations
of one-particle states.
And so what I can
do is I can sum over
a whole bunch of plane waves.
And I have to pick N factors
of k out of this list
in order to make one of these
symmetrized or anti-symmetrized
wave functions.
But then I have to
remember, as I said,
that I should not over-count
distinct set of k-values
because permutations
of these list of k's
that I have over here,
because of symmetrization
or anti-symmetrization,
will give me the same state.
So I have to be
careful about that.
Then, I go from x prime to k.
Now, the density matrix
in the k-basis I know.
It is simply e to the minus
beta, the energy which
is sum over alpha h bar squared
k alpha squared over 2m.
So I sum over the
list of k alphas
that appear in this series.
There will be n of them.
I have to
appropriately normalize
that by the N-particle partition
function, which we have yet
to calculate.
And then I go back from k to x.
Now, let's do this.
The first thing that
I mentioned last time
is that I would,
in principle, like
to sum over k1 going
over the entire list,
k2 going the entire list, k3
going over the entire list.
That is, I would like to make
the sum over k's unrestricted.
But then I have to
take into account
the over-counting that I have.
If I am looking at the case
where all of the k's are
distinct-- they don't show
any double occupancy-- then
I have over-counted by the
number of permutations.
Because any permutation would
have given me the same number.
So I have to divide by
the number of permutations
to avoid the over-counting
due to symmetrization here.
Now, when I have
something like this,
which is a multiple occupancy,
I have overdone this division.
I have to multiply
by this factor,
and that's the correct number
of over-countings that I have.
And as I said, this was a good
thing because the quantity
that I had the hardest
time for, and comes
in the normalizations
that occurs here,
is this factor of 1
over nk factorial.
Naturally, again,
all of these things
do depend on the symmetry.
So I better make sure
I indicate the index.
Whether I'm calculating this
density matrix for fermions
or bosons, it is important.
In either case-- well,
what I need to do
is to do a summation over P
here for this one and P prime
here or P prime here and P here.
It doesn't matter, there's
two sets of permutations
that I have to do.
In each case, I have to
take care of this eta P,
eta P prime.
And then the normalization.
So I divide by twice, or the
square of the square root.
I get the N factorial
product over k nk factorial.
And very nicely, the
over-counting factor
here cancels the
normalization factor
that I would have had here.
So we got that.
Now, what do we have?
We have P prime permutation
of these objects going to x,
and then we have
here P permutation
of these k numbers going to x.
I guess the first
one I got wrong.
I start with x prime.
Go through P prime to k.
And again, symmetries are
already taken into account.
I don't need to write that.
And I have the factor
of e to the minus beta h
bar squared sum over
alpha k alpha squared
over 2m divided by ZN.
OK, so let's bring all of the
denominator factors out front.
I have a ZN.
I have an N factorial squared.
Two factors of N factorial.
I have a sum over two sets of
permutations P and P prime.
The product of the associated
phase factor of their parities,
and then I have this
integration over k's.
Now, unrestricted.
Since it is unrestricted, I
can integrate independently
over each one of the k's, or
sum over each one of them.
When I sum, the sum
becomes the integral
over d cubed k alpha divided
by 2 pi-- yeah, 2 pi cubed V.
Basically, the density in
replacing the sum over k
alpha with the
corresponding integration.
So basically, this
set of factors
is what happened to that.
OK, what do we have here?
We have e to the i x--
well, let's be careful here.
I have e to the i x prime alpha
acting on k of p prime alpha
because I permuted
the k-label that
went with, say, the alpha
component here with p prime.
From here, I would
have minus because it's
the complex conjugate.
I have x alpha k p alpha,
because I permuted this by k.
I have one of these factors for
each V. With each one of them,
there is a normalization
of square root of V.
So the two of them together will
give me V. But that's only one
of the N-particle So
there are N of them.
So if I want, I can
extend this product
to also encompass this term.
And then having done so, I can
also write here e to the minus
beta h bar squared
k alpha squared
over 2m within the product.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] after
this-- is it quantity xk minus
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I forgot an a here.
What else did I miss out?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] quantity.
PROFESSOR: So I forgot the i.
OK, good?
So the V's cancel out.
All right, so that's fine.
What do we have?
We have 1 over ZN N
factorial squared.
Two sets of permutations
summed over, p and p prime.
Corresponding parities
eta p eta of p prime.
And then, I have a product
of these integrations
that I have to do that are
three-dimensional Gaussians
for each k alpha.
What do I get?
Well, first of all,
if I didn't have this,
if I just was doing
the integration of e
to the minus beta h bar
squared k squared over 2m,
I did that already.
I get a 1 over lambda cubed.
So basically, from each
one of them I will get a 1
over lambda cubed.
But the integration is
shifted by this amount.
Actually, I already did the
shifted integration here also
for one particle.
So I get the corresponding
factor of e to the minus-- ah.
I have to be a little
bit careful over here
because what I am integrating
is over k alpha squared.
Whereas, in the way that
I have the list over here,
I have x prime
alpha and x alpha,
but a different k
playing around with each.
What should I do?
I really want this
integration over k
alpha to look like
what I have over here.
Well, as I sum over
all possibilities
in each one of these terms, I
am bound to encounter k alpha.
Essentially, I have permuted
all of the k's that I originally
had.
So the k alpha has now been
sent to some other location.
But as I sum over all possible
alpha, I will hit that.
When I hit that, I will
find that the thing that
was multiplying k alpha is the
inverse permutation of alpha.
And the thing that was
multiplying k alpha here
is the inverse permutation of p.
So then I can do the
integration over k alpha easily.
And so what do I have?
I have x prime of
p prime inverse
alpha-- the inverse
permutation-- minus x
of p inverse alpha squared
pi over lambda squared.
Now, this is still
inconvenient because I
am summing over two N
factorial sets of permutations.
And I expect that since
the sum only involves
comparison of things that
are occurring N times,
as I go over the list of N
factorial permutation squared,
I will get the same
thing appearing twice.
So it is very much like when we
are doing an integration over x
and x prime, but
the function only
depends on x minus x prime.
We get a factor of volume.
Here, it is easy to
see that one of these
sums I can very easily do
because it is just repetition
of all of the results
that I have previously.
And there will be N
factorial such terms.
So doing that, I can get rid
of one of the N factorials.
And I will have only
one permutation left,
Q. And what will appear here
would be the parity of this Q
that is the combination,
or if you like,
the relative of these
two permutations.
And I have an
exponential of minus sum
over alpha x alpha minus
x prime Q alpha squared
pi over lambda squared.
And I think I forgot a factor
of lambda to the 3 [INAUDIBLE].
This factor of lambda 3.
So this is actually
the final result.
And let's see what
that precisely
means for two particles.
So let's look at two particles.
So for two particle,s I will
have on one side coordinates
of 1 prime and 2 prime.
On the right-hand side, I
have coordinates 1 and 2.
And let's see what this
density matrix tells us.
It tells us that to go from x1
prime x2 prime, a two particle
density matrix connecting
to x1 x2 on the other side,
I have 1 over the two-particle
partition function
that i haven't yet calculated.
Lambda to the sixth.
N factorial in this case is 2.
And then for two things,
there are two permutations.
So the identity
maps 1 to 1, 2 to 2.
And therefore, what
I will get here
would be exponential of minus
x1' minus x1 prime squared
pi over lambda squared minus
x2 minus x2 prime squared pi
over lambda squared.
So that's Q being
identity and identity
has essentially 0 parity.
It's an even permutation.
The next thing is when
I exchange 1 and 2.
That would have odd parity.
So I would get minus 1 for
fermions, plus for bosons.
And what I would get here
is exponential of minus x1'
minus x2 prime squared pi
over lambda squared minus x2
minus x1 prime squared
pi over lambda squared.
So essentially, one of
the terms-- the first term
is just the square of what I
had before for one particle.
I take the one-particle result,
going from 1 to 1 prime,
going from 2 to 2 prime
and multiply them together.
But then you say, I can't tell
apart 2 prime and 1 prime.
Maybe the thing that
you are calling 1 prime
is really 2 prime
and vice versa.
So I have to allow
for the possibility
that rather than
x1 prime here, I
should put x2 prime and
the other way around.
And this also corresponds
to a permutation
that is an exchange.
It's an odd parity and will
give you something like that.
Say OK, I have no
idea what that means.
I'll tell you, OK, you were
happy when I put x prime and x
here because that
was the probability
to find the particle somewhere.
So let me look at
the diagonal term
here, which is a probability.
This should give
me the probability
to find one particle
at position x1,
one particle at position x2.
Because the particles
were non-interacting,
one particle-- it
could be anywhere.
I had the 1 over V.
Is it 1 over V squared
or something like that?
Well, we find that
there is factor
out front that we
haven't yet evaluated.
It turns out that this
factor will give me a 1
over V squared.
And if I set x1
prime to x1, x2 prime
to x2, which is what I've done
here, this factor becomes 1.
But then the other factor will
give me eta e to the minus 2
pi over lambda squared
x1 minus x2 squared.
So the physical probability
to find one particle-- or more
correctly, a wave packet
here and a wave package there
is not 1 over V squared.
It's some function of the
separation between these two
particles.
So that separation
is contained here.
If I really call that
separation to be r,
this is an additional
weight that depends on r.
This is r squared.
So you can think of this
as an interaction, which
is because solely of
quantum statistics.
And what is this interaction?
This interaction V of r
would be minus kT log of 1
plus eta e to the minus 2 pi
r squared over lambda squared.
I will plot out for you
what this V or r looks
like as a function of how far
apart the centers of these two
wave packets are.
You can see that the
result depends on eta.
If eta is minus 1, which is
for the case of fermions,
this is 1 minus something.
It's something that
is less than 1.
[INAUDIBLE] would be negative.
So the whole potential would
be positive, or repulsive.
At large distances, indeed it
would be exponentially going
to 0 because I can expand
the log at large distances.
So here I have a term
that is minus 2 pi
r squared over lambda squared.
As I go towards r equals
to 0, actually things
become very bad because r
goes to 0 I will get 1 minus 1
and the log will diverge.
So basically, there is, if you
like, an effective potential
that says you
can't put these two
fermions on top of each other.
So there is a
statistical potential.
So this is for eta
minus 1, or fermions.
For the case of
bosons, eta plus 1.
It is log of 1 plus
something, so it's
a positive number
inside the log.
The potential will
be attractive.
And it will actually saturate
to a value of kT log 2
when r goes to 0.
So this is again, eta of plus
1 for the case of bosons.
So the one thing that this
formula does not have yet
is the value for this
partition function ZN.
It gives you the qualitative
behavior in either case.
And let's calculate what ZN is.
Well, basically, that
would come from noting
that the trace of
rho has to be 1.
So ZN is trace of e
to the minus beta H.
And essentially, I can take
this ZN to the other side
and evaluate this as x
e to the minus beta H x.
That is, I can calculate
the diagonal elements
of this matrix that
I have calculated--
that I have over there.
So there is an
overall factor of 1
over lambda cubed to the power
of N. I have N factorial.
And then I have a sum over
permutations Q eta of Q.
The diagonal element
is obtained by putting
x prime to be the same as x.
So I have exponential of minus
x-- sum over alpha x alpha
minus x of Q alpha.
I set x prime to
be the same as x.
Squared.
And then there's an overall
pi over lambda squared.
And if I am taking the trace,
it means that I have to do
integration over all x's.
So I'm evaluating this trace
in coordinate basis, which
means that I should
put x and x prime to be
the same for the
trace, and then I
have to sum or integrate over
all possible values of x.
So let's do this.
I have 1 over N factorial lambda
cubed raised to the power of N.
OK.
Now I have to make
a choice because I
have a whole bunch of terms
because of these permutations.
Let's do them one by one.
Let's first do the case
where Q is identity.
That is, I map
everybody to themselves.
Actually, let me write down
the integrations first.
I will do the integrations
over all pairs
of coordinates of
these Gaussians.
These Gaussians I will evaluate
for different permutations.
Let's look at the case
where Q is identity.
When Q is identity, essentially
I will put all of the x prime
to be the same as x.
It is like what I did here
for two particles and I got 1.
I do the same thing for
more than one particle.
I will still get 1.
Then, I will do the same
thing that I did over here.
Here, the next term that I
did was to exchange 1 and 2.
So this became x1 minus x2.
I'll do the same thing here.
I look at the case
where Q corresponds
to exchange of
particles 1 and 2.
And then that will
give me a factor which
is e to the minus pi over lambda
squared x1 minus x2 squared.
There are two of these making
together 2 pi over lambda
squared, which I hope
I had there, too.
But then there was a whole bunch
of other terms that I can do.
I can exchange,
let's say, 7 and 9.
And then I will get
here 2 pi over lambda
squared x7 minus x9 squared.
And there's a whole
bunch of such exchanges
that I can make in
which I just switch
between two particles
in this whole story.
And clearly, the number of
exchanges that I can make
is the number of pairs,
N N minus 1 over 2.
Once I am done with
all of the exchanges,
then I have to go to
the next thing that
doesn't have an analog
here for two particles.
But if I take three
particles, I can permute them
like a triangle.
So presumably there
would be next set
of terms, which is a permutation
that is like 1, 2, 3, 2, 3, 1.
There's a bunch of things that
involve two permutations, four
permutations, and so forth.
So there is a whole
list of things
that would go to here where
these two-particle exchanges
are the simplest class.
Now, as we shall see,
there is a systematic way
of looking at things where
the two-particle exchanges are
the first correction
due to quantum effects.
Three-particle exchanges would
be higher-order corrections.
And we can systematically
do them in order.
So let's see what happens if
we compare the case where there
is no exchange and the case
where there is one exchange.
When there is no
exchange, I am essentially
integrating over each
position over the volume.
So what I would get is V
raised to the power of N.
The next term?
Well, I have to do
the integrations.
The integrations over x3, x4,
x5, all the way to x to the N,
there is no factors.
So they will give me factors
of V. And there are N minus 2
of them.
And then I have to do the
integration over x1 and x2
of this factor, but
it's only a function
of the relative coordinate.
So there is one
other integration
that I can trivially do, which
is the center of mass gives me
a factor of V.
And then I am left
with the integral over the
relative coordinate of e
to the minus 2 pi r squared
over lambda squared.
And I forgot-- it's
very important.
This will carry a factor of eta
because any exchange is odd.
And so there will be
a factor of eta here.
And I said that I would
get the same expression
for any of my N N minus
1 over 2 exchanges.
So the result of all of
these exchange calculations
would be the same thing.
And then there would
be the contribution
from three-body
exchange and so forth.
So let's re-organize this.
I can pull out the factor
of V to the N outside.
So I would have V over lambda
cubed to the power of N.
So the first term is 1.
The next term has
the parity factor
that distinguishes
bosons and fermions, goes
with a multiplicity of pairs
which is N N minus 1 over 2.
Since I already pulled
out a factor of V to the N
and I really had V to
the N minus 1 here,
I better put a factor
of 1 over V here.
And then I just am
left with having
to evaluate these
Gaussian integrals.
Each Gaussian
integral will give me
2 pi times the
variance, which is
lambda squared divided by 2 pi.
And then there's
actually a factor of 2.
And there are three of
them, so I will have 3/2.
So what I get here is lambda
cubed divided by 2 to the 3/2.
Now, you can see that
any time I go further
in this series of
exchanges, I will
have more of these
Gaussian factors.
And whenever I have
a Gaussian factor,
I have an additional
integration to do
that has an x minus
something squared in it.
I will lose a factor of V. I
don't have that factor of V.
And so subsequent terms will
be even smaller in powers of V.
And presumably, compensated by
corresponding factors of lambda
squared-- lambda cubed.
Now, first thing to note is
that in the very, very high
temperature limit,
lambda goes to 0.
So I can forget even
this correction.
What do I get?
I get 1 over N factorial V over
lambda cubed to the power of N.
Remember that many, many
lectures back we introduced
by hand the factor of 1 over
N factorial for measuring
phase spaces of
identical particles.
And I promise to you
that we would get it
when we did identical
particles in quantum mechanics,
so here it is.
So automatically, we
did the calculation,
keeping track of
identity of particles
at the level of quantum states.
Went through the calculation and
in the high temperature limit,
we get this 1 over N
factorial emerging.
Secondly, we see that the
corrections to ideal gas
behavior emerge as a series in
powers of lambda cubed over V.
And for example, if I were to
take the log of the partition
function, I would
get log of what
I would have had classically,
which is this V over lambda
cubed to the power of N
divided by N factorial.
And then the log
of this expression.
And this I'm going to
replace with N squared.
There is not that
much difference.
And since I'm regarding this
as a correction, log of 1
plus something, I will
replace with the something
eta N squared 2V lambda cubed
2 to the 3/2 plus higher order.
What does this mean?
Once we have the
partition function,
we can calculate pressure.
Reminding you that beta
p was the log Z by dV.
The first part is
the ideal gas that we
had looked at classically.
So once I go to the appropriate
large-end limit of this,
what this gives me is
the density n over V.
And then when I look
at the derivative here,
the derivative of 1/V will give
me a minus 1 over V squared.
So I will get minus eta.
N over V, the whole
thing squared.
So I will have n squared
lambda cubed 2 to the 5/2,
and so forth.
So I see that the
pressure of this ideal gas
with no interactions
is already different
from the classical result
that we had calculated
by a factor that actually
reflects the statistics.
For fermions eta of minus 1,
you get an additional pressure
because of the kind of repulsion
that we have over here.
Whereas, for bosons
you get an attraction.
You can see that also the
thing that determines this--
so basically, this
corresponds to a second Virial
coefficient, which is minus
eta lambda cubed 2 to the 5/2,
is the volume of
these wave packets.
So essentially,
the corrections are
of the order of n
lambda cubed that
is within one of these wave
packets how many particles
you will encounter.
As you go to high temperature,
the wave packets shrink.
As you go to low temperature,
the wave packets expand.
If you like, the interactions
become more important
and you get corrections
to ideal gas wave.
AUDIENCE: You assume that
we can use perturbation,
but the higher terms actually
had a factor [INAUDIBLE].
And you can't really use
perturbation in that.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what you are worried
about is the story here,
that I took log of 1
plus something here
and I'm interested in the
limit of n going to infinity,
that finite density n over
V. So already in that limit,
you would say that
this factor really
is overwhelmingly
larger than that.
And as you say, the next
factor will be even larger.
So what is the justification
in all of this?
We have already encountered
this same problem
when we were doing
these perturbations
due to interactions.
And the answer is that what
you really want to ensure
is that not log Z,
but Z has a form
that is e to the N something.
And that something
will have corrections,
potentially that are powers
of N, the density, which
is N over V. And if you try to
force it into a perturbation
series such as this, naturally
things like this happen.
What does that really mean?
That really means that the
correct thing that you should
be expanding is,
indeed, log Z. If you
were to do the kind of
hand-waving that I did here
and do the expansion for Z, if
you also try to do it over here
you will generate
terms that look
kind of at the wrong order.
But higher order terms
that you would get
would naturally conspire so
that when you evaluate log Z,
they come out right.
You have to do this correctly.
And once you have
done it correctly,
then you can rely
on the calculation
that you did before
as an example.
And we did it correctly when
we were doing these cluster
expansions and the
corresponding calculation we
did for Q. We saw how the
different diagrams were
appearing in both
Q and the log Q,
and how they could be
summed over in log Q.
But indeed, this
mathematically looks awkward
and I kind of jumped a
step in writing log of 1
plus something that is huge
as if it was a small number.
All right.
So we have a problem.
We want to calculate
the simplest
system, which is the ideal gas.
So classically, we did
all of our calculations
first for the ideal gas.
We had exact results.
Then, let's say we
had interactions.
We did perturbations around
that and all of that.
And we saw that having to do
things for interacting systems
is very difficult.
Now, when we start to do
calculations for the quantum
problem, at least in the way
that I set it up for you,
it seems that quantum
problems are inherently
interacting problems.
I showed you that even at
the level of two particles,
it is like having an interaction
between bosons and fermions.
For three particles,
it becomes even worse
because it's not only the
two-particle interaction.
Because of the
three-particle exchanges,
you would get an additional
three-particle interaction,
four-particle interaction,
all of these things emerge.
So really, if you
want to look at this
from the perspective of
a partition function,
we already see that
the exchange term
involved having to
do a calculation that
is equivalent to calculating
the second Virial
coefficient for an
interacting system.
The next one, for the
third Virial coefficient,
I would need to look at
the three-body exchanges,
kind of like the point
clusters, four-point clusters,
all kinds of other
things are there.
So is there any hope?
And the answer is that it is
all a matter of perspective.
And somehow it is true
that these particles
in quantum mechanics
because of the statistics
are subject to all kinds of
complicated interactions.
But also, the
underlying Hamiltonian
is simple and non-interacting.
We can enumerate all
of the wave functions.
Everything is simple.
So by looking at things
in the right basis,
we should be able to calculate
everything that we need.
So here, I was kind of looking
at calculating the partition
function in the coordinate
basis, which is the worst case
scenario because the Hamiltonian
is diagonal in the momentum
basis.
So let's calculate ZN trace
of e to the minus beta H
in the basis in
which H is diagonal.
So what are the eigenvalues
and eigenfunctions?
Well, the eigenfunctions are
the symmetrized/anti-symmetrized
quantities.
The eigenvalues are simply
e to the minus beta H
bar squared k alpha
squared over 2m.
So this is basically
the thing that I
could write as the set
of k's appropriately
symmetrized or anti-symmetrized
e to the minus beta
sum over alpha H bar squared
k alpha squared over 2m k eta.
Actually, I'm going to-- rather
than go through this procedure
that we have up there
in which I wrote
these, what I need to do
here is a sum over all k
in order to evaluate the trace.
So this is inherently a
sum over all sets of k's.
But this sum is
restricted, just like what
I had indicated for you before.
Rather than trying
to do it that way,
I note that these
k's I could also
write in terms of these
occupation numbers.
So equivalently,
my basis would be
the set of occupation
numbers times the energy.
The energy is then e to the
minus beta sum over k epsilon k
nk, where epsilon
k is this beta H
bar squared k alpha
squared over 2m.
But I could do this in
principle for any epsilon k
that I have over here.
So the result that I am writing
for you is more general.
Then I sandwich it
again, since I'm
calculating the trace,
with the same state.
Now, the states have
this restriction
that I have over there.
That is, for the case of
fermions, my nk can be 0 or 1.
But there is no restriction
for nk on the bosons.
Except, of course, that there
is this overall restriction
that the sum over
k nk has to be N
because I am looking
at N-particle states.
Actually, I can remove
this because in this basis,
e to the minus
beta H is diagonal.
So I can, basically,
remove these entities.
And I'm just summing a
bunch of exponentials.
So that is good because I
should be able to do for each nk
a sum of e to something nk.
Well, the problem is this
that I can't sum over
each nk independently.
Essentially in the picture
that I have over here,
I have some n1 here.
I have some n2 here.
Some n3 here, which are
the occupation numbers
of these things.
And for that
partition function, I
have to do the sum of
these exponentials e
to the minus epsilon 1 n1,
e to the minus epsilon 2 n2.
But the sum of all of these
n's is kind of maxed out by N.
I cannot independently sum
over them going over the entire
range.
But we've seen previously
how those constraints can
be removed in
statistical mechanics.
So our usual trick.
We go to the ensemble in
which n can take any value.
So we go to the grand
canonical prescription.
We remove this constraint on n
by evaluating a grand partition
function Q, which is a sum over
all N of e to the beta mu N ZN.
So we do, essentially,
a Laplace transform.
We exchange our n with
the chemical potential mu.
Then, this constraint no
longer we need to worry about.
So now I can sum over all
of the nk's without worrying
about any constraint, provided
that I multiply with e
to the beta mu n, which
is a sum over k nk.
And then, the factor
that I have here,
which is e to the minus beta
sum over k epsilon of k nk.
So essentially for each
k, I can independently
sum over its nk of e to the
beta mu minus epsilon of k nk.
Now, the symmetry issues remain.
This answer still
depends on whether or not
I am calculating things
for bosons or fermions
because these sums are
differently constrained
whether I'm dealing
with fermions.
In which case, nk
is only 0 or 1.
Or bosons, in which case
there is no constraint.
So what do I get?
For the case of fermions,
I have a Q minus,
which is product over all k.
And for each k, the nk
takes either 0 or 1.
So if it takes 0, I will
write e to the 0, which is 1.
Or it takes 1.
It is e to the beta
mu minus epsilon of k.
For the case of bosons,
I have a Q plus.
Q plus is, again, a product
over Q. In this case,
nk going from 0 to infinity, I
am summing a geometric series
that starts as 1, and
then the subsequent terms
are smaller by a factor of
beta mu minus epsilon of k.
Actually, for future
reference note
that I would be able to
do this geometric sum
provided that this combination
beta mu minus epsilon of k
is negative.
So that the subsequent terms
in this series are decaying.
Typically, we would be
interested in things
like partition functions,
grand partition functions.
So we have something like log of
Q, which would be a sum over k.
And I would have either
the log of this quantity
or the log of this
quantity with a minus sign.
I can combine the
two results together
by putting a factor of minus
eta because in taking the log,
over here for the bosons I
would pick a factor of minus 1
because the thing is
in the denominator.
And then I would
write the log of 1.
And then I have in both
cases, a factor which
is e to the beta mu
minus epsilon of k.
But occurring with
different signs
for the bosons and
fermions, which again I
can combine into a single
expression by putting a minus
eta here.
So this is a general
result for any Hamiltonian
that has the characteristic
that we wrote over here.
So this does not have to
be particles in a box.
It could be particles in
a harmonic oscillator.
These could be energy levels
of a harmonic oscillator.
All you need to do is to
make the appropriate sum
over the one-particle
levels harmonic oscillator,
or whatever else you have,
of these factors that
depend on the
individual energy levels
of the one-particle system.
Now, one of the things
that we will encounter
having made this transition
from canonical, where we knew
how many particles we had, to
grand canonical, where we only
know the chemical potential,
is that we would ultimately
want to express things in terms
of the number of particles.
So it makes sense to
calculate how many particles
you have given that you have
fixed the chemical potential.
So for that we
note the following.
That essentially, we were able
to do this calculation for Q
because it was a
product of contributions
that we had for the individual
one-particle states.
So clearly, as far as this
normalization is concerned,
the individual one-particle
states are independent.
And indeed, what we can say
is that in this ensemble,
there is a classical probability
for a set of occupation numbers
of one particle
states, which is simply
a product over the different
one-particle states of e
to the beta mu minus epsilon
k nk appropriately normalized.
And again, the
restriction on n's
being 0 or 1 for
fermions or anything
for bosons would be
implicit in either case.
But in either case, essentially
the occupation numbers
are independently taken
from distributions
that I've discussed [INAUDIBLE].
So you can, in
fact, independently
calculate the average
occupation number
that you have for each one of
these single-particle states.
And it's clear that you could
get that by, for example,
bringing down a
factor of nk here.
And you can bring
down a factor of nk
by taking a derivative of Q
with respect to beta epsilon k
with a minus sign
and normalizing it,
so you would have log.
So you would have an
expression such as this.
So you basically would
need to calculate,
since you are taking
derivative with respect
to epsilon k the corresponding
log for which epsilon
k appears.
Actually, for the
case of fermions,
really there are
two possibilities.
n is either 0 or 1.
So you would say that the
expectation value would
be when it is 1, you have e to
the beta epsilon of k minus mu.
Oops.
e to the beta mu
minus epsilon of k.
The two possibilities
are 1 plus e
to the beta mu
minus epsilon of k.
So when I look at
some particular state,
it is either empty.
In which case, contributes 0.
Or, it is occupied.
In which case, it
contributes this weight,
which has to be
appropriately normalized.
If I do the same thing
for the case of bosons,
it is a bit more
complicated because I
have to look at this series
rather than geometric 1
plus x plus x squared
plus x cubed is
1 plus x plus 2x squared plus
3x cubed, which can be obtained
by taking the derivative
of the appropriate log.
Or you can fall back
on your calculations
of geometric series
and convince yourself
that it is essentially the same
thing with a factor of minus
here.
So this is fermions
and this is bosons.
And indeed, I can put the
two expressions together
by dividing through this
factor in both of them
and write it as 1
over Z inverse e
to the beta epsilon
of k minus eta,
where for convenience
I have introduced
Z to be the contribution
e to the beta.
So for this system of
non-interacting particles
that are identical,
we have expressions
for log of the grand partition
function, the grand potential.
And for the average
number of particles,
which is an appropriate
derivative of this,
expressed in terms of the
single-particle energy
levels and the
chemical potential.
So next time, what
we will do is we
will start this
with this expression
for the case of the
particles in a box
to get the pressure of
the ideal quantum gas
as a function of mu.
But we want to
write the pressure
as a function of density, so
we will invert this expression
to get density as a
function of-- chemical
potential as a function of
density [INAUDIBLE] here.
And therefore, get the
expression for pressure
as a function of density.